this episode brought to you by Devil May
Cry 5 and over-the-top action fill game
rated M for Mature now available on Xbox
one
[Music]
previously on Xbox
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to and
welcome to the final installment of X
month well with x-men the last Dan
leaving the bad taste of an iminium dick
in those people's mouths it only made
sense to cut out the middle x-man so to
speak and focus on the one that people
loved most even before the movies
Wolverine had always proven to be x-men
most popular character even spawning his
own successful comic series so was
decided a new movie series called x-men
origins was to begin each film going
into the backstory of a different mutant
there was actually talks for a while of
Ian McKellen doing an x-men origins
magneto movie and everyone wanted to see
how their most popular character
Wolverine fared with his own film well
let me tell you this is what they do
with the most popular characters I'd
hate to see what they do with the shit
stain body parts of their unpopular ones
[Applause]
x-men fans have their differences but
one thing they can all agree on is x-men
origins Wolverine sucks what should have
been the easiest movie to make the most
awesome badass and fun became the most
inconsistent dull and downright baffling
in terms of story and character choices
most x-men fans and not x-men fans agree
it's the worst of the movies and we're
here to analyze how this middle club
flick happened let's wrap up X month the
right way well away this is x-men
origins Wolverine it opens up in 1845
well my knowledge of Wolverine only goes
back to 1974 so I guess I just have to
judge it less as an annotation and more
as a shitty movie we see a young Logan
as we discover his original name is
Jimmy so wait Jimmy we're brothers Jimmy
oh god I so wish they retitled this now
as his house is broken into when a
stranger apparently killed his father
the kid for the most part plays a young
Wolverine pretty well but you have to
watch out when the person in charge
directs you poorly in a shot yep that's
the one this kid should have a therapy
session with the one from Christmas
story live oh the scary hilarious
consequences of bad direction he extends
out his bone claw tell me that's the
name of a D&D character or a wrestler
okay good
and he stabs the man to death but the
man reveals that he was his father all
along well let's dive into these
characters we just met to appreciate why
this is so dramatic or we're just
leaving before we establish why we're
supposed to care get used to that it
looks like his brother Victor who will
later become saber-tooth okay that I do
need clarification on
okay good were you away into a title
sequence where they show every war they
ever signed up for Marvel Civil War
Saving Private Ryan Reynolds x-men
Apocalypse Now and through all of it
Wolverine grew up fast into Hugh Jackman
and just kind of stayed that age for the
next hundred years until these two
movies and then suddenly white hair and
Sabretooth grew up into Liev Schreiber
who finally perfected his dolphin jump
in all seriousness the credits are
probably the best part of the movie
which saying that out loud makes me
realize how much trouble we're in
they're captured though and approached
by William Stryker played this time by
Danny Huston your sentence was carried
out by a firing squad at ten hundred
hours who offers them the chance of a
lifetime
put together a special team with special
privileges I'm calling it the ass
vengers
they of course agree yeah if you were to
tell me the guy on this plane most
likely to get a game-changing Marvel
movie would be the one from the proposal
I'd ask how you did things so wrong yet
so right at the same time it's funny
weird it's probably not as intimidating
as having a gun or fingernails of a bag
lady did the film's credit
it was mostly cast well Schreiber is a
decent saber-tooth we know Ryan Reynolds
will be a good Deadpool and maybe
Wolverine listens to black eyed peas in
Nigeria where they tried to keep a low
profile walking like the poster for
every Expendables movie cool his mutant
power is to bug funny people to death
the enemy stops them in the elevator
though they took the alabama's deadpool
reveals his mutant power is using gun
Tata
an email said your prince was in trouble
we're here to transfer funds know what
this but that is nothing a souvenir
it was like there after a rock that the
crown Lord said was from a small village
and he thought was just a useless
souvenir so in hindsight they could have
just asked him for the damned thing
instead of claiming so many goddamn
lives he says that it's sacred did he
break his neck or adjust it
no thank you can you crack my back next
hey you know what'd be interesting
showing us how saber-tooth got his
bloodlust I mean it is called origins
but we never got to him see how these
two became who they are what happened
when they ran away from home
they just went into war how did that
impact them as characters how did it
change them what were they like before
what were they like after the idea
behind an origin story especially a
prequel is to see how their actions and
environment shape who they are but who
they are in the first 10 minutes it's
pretty much exactly who they are by the
last 10 minutes the biggest change is
from a little boy to a grown man and
that only lasts a minute stuff happens
to them all throughout the movie but we
never see how it alters them in any way
this Wolverine is the exact same as this
Wolverine he just doesn't have metal
claws and he's called Jimmy ma we can't
just let you walk away take this for
example
Jimmy leads the team and we cut to him
years later in the mountains with a
woman who the hell is she
I mean her name is Kayla but who the
hell is she we don't see how they met
how they know each other what she's like
we just know they're suddenly together
and they smile so lovingly at each other
that she's clearly dead was it the wars
which way Viet Civil World War Nam I
can't see hugh jackman never slumming a
performance but even he doesn't seem as
into it as usual look at his face here
it's he's being given the origin story
of his name he doesn't look like he's
letting it sink in enough that it'll one
day become his identity he looks more
like he's going through his grocery list
in his head so he told ke Akua Tzu
that the moon had asked for flowers in
every night he's not even hiding his
accent half the time so you're gonna
take me to this element you have those
powers over me I ain't even hissing you
tell me where Victor is I'm just gonna
ask nicely my ladies go bye come on bub
he sounds like an angry and constipated
Rocco or I can kill Creed Stryker and
pretty much everyone you hate in this
world let's put another ramp Alma Bob a
but Jimmy's brother finds like you to
remember her name if I said it and
Poor's fake blood all over her I
originally meant this as a joke as we
find out later that is what actually
happens if I can tell from a distance
that's not real how can this dumbass
with heightened senses not pick that up
even this supposed big emotional moment
seems have asked as the music and his
screaming seems randomly cut short
this whole film feels like it was
written by a Google program protagonist
befriends love interest for five minutes
of screen time old friend D trades
protagonist at exactly 30 minute mark
protagonist screens for five point one
seconds they should equal you crying why
aren't you crying you're not from around
here are you actually my name's
Sabretooth I chose it based on a story
where a spirit came down to earth and
you know that I chose it cuz it's cool
why can't that be a thing with the cat
dragon guys whatever this is take it
outside
now Skeeter ain't hurtin nobody Jimmy
fine Sabretooth then they have an
amazingly bad action sequence that you
can barely make out because it's shot
and edited I think by an actual
Wolverine yeah they say a firing squad
tickles but a log that's what takes the
mighty Wolverine out of action he wakes
up in a hospital where Stryker
approaches him just in time to do his
Pacino six years my children come to
play with their toys
Stryker offers Jimmy a procedure to make
him indestructible despite him already
being indestructible by giving him an
anime atiim skeleton oh I'm so glad we
haven't seen this imager yet Hugh
Jackman's acted this being experiment to
stick so much he's literally playing it
in asleep or dead I'd believe that too
well I guess I can't
we just can't resuscitate this movie he
wakes up though hearing that they want
to erase his memory and he goes after
them the first of tasteful glimpse of me
bottom for the lights
directors think if they just emphasize
an axe that makes a good Axemen movie
right here on this day
of course it wouldn't be a comic book
origin story without the friggin nicest
silver-haired angels that offer parental
advice to our main character both err
kindness might be characterized as
borderline insanity if you would give
shelter to a naked man breathing heavily
in your barn it's cool yeah it's usually
bigger than that just had a rough night
well I see no threat emulating from this
feel free to stay in our home and play
with my grandchildren
so Jimmy does by using them earlier
apparently forgot he had claws as he
looked incredibly surprised when they
pop out of his knuckles after he picked
them up from whom town what is up with
those effects it looks like someone
ripped off the fangs from the tiger an
ice age and glue them onto his hand the
first film had half the budget of this
one and they made them look okay
this flick I keep expecting cartoon
faces to pop on them like ah well
logically I should throw your crazy ass
out but we're Canadian we have a
stereotype to keep up mostly the old man
gives Jimmy his son's jacket who would
thank god also happened to be a
muscle-bound beefcake the missus brings
in some refreshments for them I brought
you oh dear I'll have to make more
with the Nexus in the barn well glad to
know we elevated from blue sky animation
to DreamWorks Animation in the same film
blow him to bits let's see if I can
survive that buzzer he survived exactly
that
you know I'm not gonna lie actually
enjoying a few minutes with the old
couple that's probably why they got rid
of it so fast we get a chase scene that
on paper sounds pretty cool with a
chopper motorcycle and chief flying
around and blowing shit up but once
again it's unedited like a monkey
shaking you by the shoulders going back
we said when the trailer holds longer on
the shot than the actual movie does by
the way if you're wondering if lighting
the gas leading to a giant explosion and
walking away without looking in 2009 was
cliched no it was embarrassingly cliched
[Applause]
[Music]
Devil May Cry 5 is the most amazing game
ever you can do anything with it chop
vegetables clean the bathroom get in
fights with it sometimes it fights back
but mostly you just play it playing it
is the best thing to do with it because
it's a game you know why this series is
awesome it's the fifth one for crying
out loud
if you ever need to just slice and dice
and demons while looking hella nice this
is the game for you it features three
demon hunters each with a unique play
style you can play as Dante Nero or the
mysterious new protagonist v with all
three characters bring the equal amounts
of Swagger and skill you can fight off
demon hoarders with as much smoke and
sexy style as you can imagine because
imagining Devils crying is sexy you
don't need to take my word for it but do
because it's me but even if you didn't
hear some other people that say things
bleeding cool calls at an elegant
symphony of obliteration that's amazing
dual shockers calls it one hell of a
good time equally amazing my cat says
meow amazing and game rankles Devil May
Cry the perfect action game that's so
amazing I'm just gonna say the word
amazing again but in a slightly higher
pitch amazing so come on and kick some
demon ass with Devil May Cry 5 and
remember games play best on Xbox one to
get Devil May Cry 5 do not call this
number but instead go to a video game
store or purchase it online go now go
now finish this video actually because
you know I'm in it but you know it go
now afterwards after you watch the video
just to just do it right now
what are you waiting for just go go
what's wrong with you it's an amazing
game everyone knows it's amazing game to
do it do it what what are you sick are
you sick this game can cure you it's
medicine definitely cry 5 is medicine
I'm legally required to tell you the
Devil May Cry 5 is not medicine but it
makes you feel so good that's like
medicine
what do you can do anyway you're sick
you might as well play video games
what's wrong with you
go get it your problem
go go
[Applause]
so after summing up how people are
liking this movie Colonel this is
turning into a disaster riots - Vegas
where I'm not gonna lie at this point
I'd rather just see him gamble than
carry out whatever mission he was on
three cloth stud I totally watch that
movie dukes knows Fred dukes develop a
bit eating disorder we all gotta cause
mechanisms
oh yeah so you remember an x-men a
character called the blob one of the
more famous foes whose mutant power was
an indestructible obese body well no
he's just a dude who put on a lot of
weight still a mutant but his powers
have absolutely nothing to do with his
size he just let himself go it's like
saying Superman is still an alien but he
doesn't have superhuman strength he just
mimics pumping iron a lot blob head
bitch tits you know with help you see
things are becoming you think an actor
who isn't over way playing and
overweight character would be called fat
face Jimmy beats enough to get
information on where saber-tooth and
Stryker are and it looks like the two of
them are out hunting another mutant a
young Peter but down a bitch just
remember when we meet up yours later and
I grow my hair blonde and I never talk
we are never to reference this blob says
Jimmy can find another mutant who
escaped strikers experiments named
gambit I don't really know why he looks
like Sawyer from laws but he gives up
the only cool shot in the movie so I
have no choice but to like it
two years are oh no that's kind of funny
to tell me something you mean but still
not as funny as what he calls a bat you
even know how to kill me I'm gonna cut
you goddamn head off there's literally
just knocked out there so fast
and I don't know aeronautics but I'm
pretty sure you can't helicopter down
via Kane the same way Dixie Kong does
with her hair your gabot you and Dixie
Kahn should not be mentioned in the same
sentence saber-toothed escape says Jimmy
and gambits day for honestly no reason
to fight this is a cartoon all that's
missing is atomic Jewry scream when he
falls give it finally agrees to help
Jimmy get striker as striker puts the
finishing touches on his latest mutant
experiment a few more hours and he will
respond to my commands we're gonna make
Momo a reality urban legend my ass jimmy
finally catches up with striker and you
gotta love how our lead is so
unimpressive he's not even worth a head
turned I've learned that nothing
motivates the men and your family like
vanish but gasp what's-her-face is still
alive wow that's so underwhelming and
not worth shitting a care that even
Jimmy doesn't know how to react to it he
just kind of awkwardly kneels and lets
out a reverse quack Wolverine it's
revealed that she worked with Stryker
because he's holding her sister hostage
and her mutant power is she can touch
people and influence them to think
whatever she like now on top of asking
why the hell she doesn't just use that
power to have Stryker and her sister
over I mean cry from a storytelling
standpoint how cool it would have been
if we saw them meet she holds his hand
and from that point on we have to
re-watch the scene and ask was this real
love or just her mutant power there
could have been a brilliant dramatic
setup here but because that would mean
making a connection with the characters
instead of just doing things got to do
this thing gather do this thing God do
this thing
we're developed now Jimmy tells her
exactly what he told Fox after seeing
this movie miss Lulu got play so
obviously it's time to fight those who
wronged him or he walks away Wolverine
you know this is also amazingly
underwhelming you gotta wonder what
striker was talking about at the end of
x2 remember when he was bringing up his
past
you're an animal then your nano now if
you really know about your past what
kind of person you are the work we did
together we stole a rock give you some
tiny two claws and this lady you barely
know didn't die we were animals animals
and I guess Sabretooth reveals why he
suddenly betrayed his brother give me
the adamantium teske we heard you would
never survive the operation so over a
hundred years of knowing this guy and
you totally the tram because you just
wanted an ax man him in your bones
something the guy says wouldn't work
anyway I think tender hard and clumpy
better have a more complex rivalry than
that returns and helps free all the
mutant cameos and yeah let's get this
over with the mutant that was being
worked on earlier was Deadpool well you
said you
by god it's like the comic leaped onto
the screen just try to film you figure
that how to shut you up but brilliant
rolling can't keep one silent for long
[Music]
hey I'm just keeping the kid Sally
that's not what happens in this film
though the whole macaque you imagine
every copy of this movie they made
afterwards they put that part in and
that's where it ends they were all the
crabs and everything oh my god right
rattles get on that as Deadpool uses all
the mutant powers surgically given to
him the dumb it hurts
and Sabretooth right the hell out of
nowhere decides he likes Jimmy again
then they decide to fight him
all this high-tech ingenuity and you
have to type in your commands like a
1980s RPG got some great Spaceballs
logic working here it's a competition of
which sucky effect can destroy the other
toy story claws are invaders in laser
beams only the crappiest shall survive
they end up defeating him but as Jimmy
says this isn't over this doesn't change
anything between us Viktor we're
brothers each other
don't bless your memories are raised and
I go working for a magnet man you know
how it goes
who gives a dick is dying though and
Jimmy goes to say goodbye
really
you don't look it you don't even seem
annoyed to be dying you can say things
all you want movie but unless you commit
to it
striker shoots to Ana Mannion bullets
into his head and yep that's twice they
try to fake you out that he might die oh
and here's another nail-biter
Spider Man might not be back in Eid
games he far from home I should make you
pull the trigger but that wouldn't make
us no better than you walking to your
feet bleed
well now result in tons of people dying
but why start making sense now well
hider mr. clean mighty glad to know you
you're safe now
boy huh must've missed those on the
x-ray also weird the Jimmy never told
Xavier exactly what he did remember yeah
I woke up around a destroy power plant
on this exact date yes I was totally
there with that starting point I'm sure
we can piece together where you came
from guess it doesn't matter
good luck a shame that gambit guy didn't
get my screen time but I'm sure he'll
get in our starring role in a big
moneymaker
and that was x-men origins Jimmy I'm a
Wolverine I mean Jimmy yeah because this
definitely was not Wolverine Wolverine
is one of the coolest characters in
comic book history but none of that
would be reflected if you went off of
this movie alone it doesn't add up to
the continuity the film's it doesn't
please any comic fans it's way too
boring and cliched to entertain
newcomers it's just a disaster x-men has
had a shaky history in both comics and
film but when it comes to the absolute
worst x-men flick there is you need look
no further than x-men origins Jimmy and
that was X month I hope everybody had a
good time I was in the animated intro so
I just assumed I'd be flying around his
Road oh yeah that was more of a style
thing I'm I'm not gonna be an x-men
hotel
aren't we all x-men in our hearts yeah
we are now congratulations I'll make it
up to you later just get out of here
[Music]
so I hope you enjoyed X month ever ready
for God's sake I take offense at dirt
I'm not having us at the ax men then
why'd you have us in the intro I just
told the animator to draw something cool
yeah that was cool now let's actually do
it I can't expose solvers I'm getting
out of here great I'm ready
how did you even I'm ready for my cameo
as sadly I'm not doing that
besides didn't cameo anywhere else sure
I did here look you see you always need
a cameo from the Creator didn't create
the nostalgia critic sure I did look
when a man and a woman love each other
very much credits oh great we're here
for X month oh my god it's already over
and you didn't invite us it was your
idea exactly oh my god I keep just go
away before other people spontaneously
appear on my corner yeah you both
advertised critic yeah none of us were
excellent okay I'm sorry I'll make it up
to you all somehow oh you mean by
reviewing the movie starring a person
you never wanted to talk about it stop
right there I know how this works you
bring up a movie or person I don't want
to talk about and once I talk about them
their picture pops up and I'm stuck
reviewing it well I'm not falling for it
this time so get out well I think she
was just talking about
it's like Christmas with the Hitler's
they're known about to anything I'm in
this town sir could a guy remembered so
you don't have to
[Laughter]
hello dog walker here and the hunger
project is this week's charity shout out
this organization envisions a world
where every woman man and child leads a
healthy fulfilling life of self-reliance
and dignity their mission is to end
hunger and poverty by pioneering
sustainable grassroots empowered
centered strategies and advocating for
their widespread adoption in countries
throughout the world through their work
to end hunger they recognize these ten
principles as being fundamental to The
Hunger Project human dignity gender
equality empowerment leverage
interconnectedness sustainability social
transformation holistic approach
decentralisation
and transformative leadership world
hunger can be ended but not by merely
doing more of the same hunger is
primarily a human issue and ending
hunger requires principles that are
consistent with shared humanity if you
agree with this and want to see hunger
and as much as these people do then
click on the link and donate to their
wonderful cause
you
[Music]